otra vez en cinco semanas que las
personas en brasil pasan a la calle para
protestar contra jair bolsonaro en estos
momentos hay manifestaciones en al menos
290 ciudades y tato está en el medio del
escándalo por la compra fraudulenta de
la vacuna de la india pop-up sin
recortamos que portar está cruzado de
prevaricación es decir de hacerse la
vista gorda ante las denuncias de una
compra fraudulenta de esta basura de la
línea compres un mil por ciento superior
al estipulado y para alimentar en sus
huertos esquemas de sobornos anoche el
tribunal supremo de minutos
pero precisamente por eso es cantado
mientras tanto calificado su popularidad
la encuesta muestra que habría perdido
parte de sus electores
a las elecciones presidenciales